welcome back to another episode of trash
Tuesday with special guest Rick Glassman
I am Rick glasman here with Esther
pavitsky who doesn't have a side and
kalila who is left-sided correct and
this is my good side now okay go ahead
Rick what is it about the other side
that scares you so much because we
switched we had to start oh you had to
let everybody know that we had to switch
oh we could edit that out it's just but
you actually were so avoidant you did
not want to switch I said I think kalila
likes that side and you didn't want to
let her have that even though what I
said was let's have her say that on the
podcast why so because I want to have
that conversation what's the good side I
believe it I believe it exists nice to
live with symmetry
she's not symmetrical but both sides are
bad at first
Little Creek yes my right side I mean
you just said it people can be
objectively ugly right and it's all
about Symmetry and my I am the most
asymmetric person I have one eye smaller
than the other two we know it's not as
obvious as yours I think and um just my
everything is a little bit stranger on
the right side I don't think that beauty
is objective I'm saying there are some
things that aren't as subjective
but like there are some people that
you take a you take a sample of a
hundred guys and 100 girls and then you
take a sample of 200 random people and
they say pretty or not pretty there's
going to be some that yeah but that's
based on sorry are you gonna be here the
whole podcast it's very thrilled can we
do something about Esther Esther Esther
can we turn the shrill down maybe bring
our parents so something could be funny
go ahead
[Music]
oh my god Julie how exciting you guys
Julie is an FDA approved morning after
pill that helps stop pregnancy before it
starts go to juliecare.com to learn more
or find Julie at your nearest CVS Target
or Walmart today that's
juliecare.co to learn more our next
partner is athletic greens and we take
ag1 a lot over here I gave ag1 a try
because I wanted better gut health I
wanted to get my Greens in without
having to think about it and do guessing
games and play with Bunches of pills and
if you're looking for an easier way to
take supplements athletic greens is
giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to
athleticgreens.com Tuesday that's
athleticgreens.com
Tuesday check it out this show is
sponsored by betterhelp visit
betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today to
get 10 off your first month that's
better help a
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday you guys
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way go to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
you made the same joke last night Esther
was due in 20 minutes and she goes I'm
not gonna do the whole 20. and he said
well of course not without her parents
here
it was fun seeing you last night doing
that show I gotta say I haven't seen you
in a while and it works when you walk up
with the music and a little dancing that
we did and everything it works did you
bring her up no we just were in the back
of Soho house and we were in a big group
of crowded cool people and I saw Rick
across the room for the first time and
I'll do my impression of Esther when she
saw me
and I walked up to him he popped up like
and I when I'm near Rick my body just
sort of goes with it and also mind
please let him know popped up unbeat on
oh yes on Beat it was on the fourth why
don't you say what happened please
please and then he swirled me around and
dipped me and all the cool hot people
were impressed and they all went like
this
do you want to change shirts
this shirt it's a vintage diesel pretend
you're going down a roller coaster and
let everybody see what I just saw
[Laughter]
body shaming my arms no your armpits are
wet oh you're mine they are your armpits
never Sweat Right they sweat yeah but we
just started
constantly sweating dripping sweat if
you say treadmill she starts to perspire
I just need to think one thought in my
armpits are wet if even if it's a
positive thought it's called
hyperhidrosis oh sorry I relate thank
you mother
um now listen Rick so people are ugly is
what you're saying I'm saying I'm saying
I don't think beauty is as and I say the
same I think the same thing
comedy I don't think that comedy and
Beauty are as subjective because people
so you're saying since the dawn of time
um there's been a beauty standard
someone can be born and just know
inherently what is good looking what is
not good looking because wouldn't you
argue that I already said no so your
point is go ahead but so tell us if 200
people are in a room and we do uh a
survey of who's good looking and who's
not good looking
um no it's very it's based on the time
and culturally as well like if you go
like we're here in America in 20 what is
it
23 23 2023 there is what a flex wow
you're so cool you don't even know the
year whatever I don't think about that
kind of stuff a little guy cool guys
here yeah and what day is it by the way
some people like for example
um
I I bet you like a lot of people will
comment I've seen on this podcast when
you guessed on mine Esther's actually
not that ugly because I got to know her
really they got to know her a little bit
and she's funny when funny people are
around so like things change and the
meter moves a little bit but but
typically like nobody's gonna ask Esther
to to campaign for something if it
weren't for her funny parents does that
make sense
be Maybelline
no one would say maybe a twinkling they
know it's Maybelline we don't know that
well we'll see look you're trying to say
oh you're trying to say
that beauty you just said before we
started rolling that beauty is
there are some people I forgot yeah well
there are some people
um and I'll go and say it we're not
these people that are like they're like
whoa no you're very ugly too that's why
we see each other in each other
I I don't see that any of me and you
literally or metaphorically no no but
you do no you're you're an ugly person
I'm an average guy
I when I look in the mirror I see Rick
Glassman we know go to a clip and be
just behind you
wait a second I'm not understanding your
point because you're kind of arguing
your own point in front of me so you're
saying yeah I know he's totally switchy
swatchy so there is there is a beauty
standard but again that beauty standard
varies in time and place
but either of those beauty standards are
still based on previous references of
beauty and what the culture decides one
of the variables is very very influenced
by social standards and what is being
marketed and what people are doing and
what trends absolutely but if you look
at any period of time for example there
are people who are not uh uh what's his
name Adam Driver I think is such a good
looking guy but he's like got an
interesting non-symmetrical he's got big
character and he has
hipsy girl I think you're Adam Driver
huh yeah
yeah wait a second
yeah
you're Adam drivers good looking just
because his nose is big and he's very
Jewish looking and his posture isn't the
best talking about me now because I
think like I grew up around
um people well I grew up in a culture
that revered sumo wrestlers say for
instance I grew up in Asia and these
guys were were Playboys they would date
like really hot models and they were
what like 400 500 pound dudes and I've
always had a thing for fat Asian dudes
and so you know
um everyone at home goes we know but
like objectively and this is I mean not
objectively subjectively I
this is gonna sound pretty harsh but I
basically don't look at white guys twice
like it's very hard for me to find a
white person like a white guy like just
to get my loins going in that direction
but if you put a you know a portly Asian
guy in front of me my loins will get
going but then over here in America they
it it kind of took a while for Asian men
to be viewed that way and it's still not
you know the the sumo wrestler look is
still not a thing here that's such a
superpower to not be attracted to white
men I know like you can just like
destroy their lives not care I mean I've
dated them it's just it my you know my
preferences are a little bit shaped
they're shaped differently because I
grew up in a different continent yeah I
mean so Asian guys are number one for me
don't you feel like what she just said
completely blew your argument out of the
water absolutely I stand corrected
I'm saying it's just not completely
subjective for example
people like pizza
a lot of people say pizza's delicious
some people don't like pizza some people
don't like white pizzas
however I love white pizza though okay
great white pizza if it's bread you'll
eat it people like pizza so what I'm
saying is there is a deviation to that
but like if you were like salmon pot pie
I'm sure people will eat that but that's
not classically beautiful no it is if
that's what you grew up thinking was
classically beautiful then you will eat
that yes some people like salmon pot pie
yeah most people like pizza
people that you know were exposed but
that's that's what I'm saying you are
one of the most of the people I know so
are the people that I'm going to meet
I'm not here saying Beauty needs to be a
certain thing I'm just not following
this idea that everything is so
subjective food comedy looks it there
are kind of like standards
but there are no there's not literally
beauty standards that I think is ruining
company absolutely yes I could literally
start my own planet and say I'm the
standard of beauty and yours will go by
and that will that will never play why
not
start your own Planet you you almost
pooped your pants because he was a
little bit late getting here
that some people
do you ever look at a girl or a guy and
be like she's hot he's hot and think
that most people would agree
no okay I'm wrong I I see what you're
saying there are people that I could be
like oh he's objectively good looking
but I'm not attracted maybe so that's
based on what you saw everything is so
is your flavor profile and your your
palette exactly we're all a reflection
of the culture around us deep man deep
so that means that it could if it
different
it would be different and we wouldn't
know agreed okay
so
but here we are growing up the way we
grew up yeah looking at the things
eating the things watching the things we
have this idea of what we are into at
this moment in time and with that it's
not as fluid as everyone's saying
everything all people are beautiful but
it's all made up so are the words we're
using but you still understand them yeah
so we make stuff up we have pattern
recognition as these humans and we have
this shorthand and we communicate the
way we do physically emotionally words
music and we have an idea of what the
world is and what we like and as a
collective
people there are people that are
relatively
uglier
people
would you disagree
um
under this under what Society has
decided upon yes but then if you're
going to follow that it's like so are we
sticking with that because under that
societal dueling like what our culture
has told us it's like only tall blonde
women who look like Pam Anderson are
that's the standard of beauty I grew up
in the 90s yeah no exactly but that's my
point it's like but yes for a while big
tits were correct me if I'm wrong all
the rage
and now we don't need them anymore but
the only reason they were that was
because Pam Anderson's so it can change
absolutely so if it can change it can be
anything at any point I don't we don't
need big tits anymore nope all you need
is a nice ass and a good face but then
it got replaced with the ass but what
happens to the you know what I mean it
just it's a bummer it's a bummer for
guys used to be coming next yeah and
that's and that's that's what's exciting
that's what's exciting and that's kind
of like what the the younger Generations
have to offer like kind of like the
elected officials what we're voting for
who's who's gonna create these new
policies who's going to represent us
that's why it's important that we have
people
kind of go in there and be like oh yeah
like this is good looking and this is
funny and this is tasty and things
change absolutely yes yeah
very good but
do you guys think Dumb and Dumber is a
funny movie
I don't remember yeah
of course what do you mean of course
well there's Nostalgia tied to it for me
because my dad and I watched it and the
the movie theater in the Philippines was
so packed that people were like sitting
on the aisles like not even on even in
the Philippines Dumb and Dumber was
funny hilarious would you say
you understand that some people might
not think it's funny but objectively
like
that's a funny movie yeah but I I feel
like again
I don't know if this speaks to your
point or our point but
um it's not as funny to me today if I
were to watch it today with fresh eyes
it would be a little bit different are
you trying to argue that Dumb and Dumber
is objectively funny what I'm saying is
in the same in the same way that's the
movie you chose
yeah it's not the funniest movie in the
world but it's a very funny big broad
movie okay and it's just like you don't
think there's a ton of smart people
right now that will look at that and I'm
I don't remember anything about the
movie but my top of my intelligence
guess is that everyone even in this room
right now would look at that movie today
and be like this is stupid and not funny
and it won't make me laugh out loud okay
then you're pretty
[Music]
you're a beautiful girl thank
you thanks well what do you think about
pay mail is there now versus Pam
Anderson Back Then
I used to I used to be I was so into
pain management and Carmen Electra and I
didn't have a printer growing up
I know I didn't have a computer Rick I
didn't have a computer until I was 24
years old
honestly I don't know why I'm undressing
but that might be for the best I had a
computer when I was 10 and I did not use
it for good what did you use it for
cyber sex chat rooms pretending at 10
yeah
pretending to be a woman that looks like
Pam Anderson did you catch fish people
then yeah and what would you say I did
chat room stuff I vote do you think
maybe we I feel like I recognize you
what kind of dirty things did he say I
just would were you trying to get MP3s
no I would download pictures of naked
women you had my attention and send them
to people oh my chat rooms right and say
that now the women that you downloaded
were they just
were they pretty women or ugly women or
no no they were like what the standard
of beauty was at the time that's all I'm
saying man oh God that's all I'm saying
you thought that these people would be
attracted to this type of woman because
of what I saw on TV everything we're
doing we're all Stardust man everything
we're doing is based on our what we're
inspired and our experience so what is
to stop me from starting a whole new
cult and being like I'm the hottest
thing you've been trying to do it for a
decade how's it working for you
sweetheart
I think we should
so you've
had fished people I mean and I did it
and I said I was a girl
why are we not going to talk about the
Pamela Anderson Carmen Electra printer
stuff do we go back to that we can okay
let's start there but let's definitely
not gloss over the girl stuff what could
that be
um I uh I don't know how old I was
probably like 10-ish and chat rooms are
new and Rick I think you and I hooked up
in a chat room I think you guys must
have I think yeah it was girl on girl
and I would that would make sense
um yeah I would uh I would talk and and
uh I would pretend I was a girl
wait I thought we were going through
Carmen Electra printer oh sure yeah
first you seemed so desperate to go back
to it take us there it was just it's a
fun it's a funny memory go for it
um I would go
[Music]
write that down what time are we
Esther Gotta Laugh how far
which is probably last time Esther would
have been hot
so
I was so ugly when I was 16.
16 15. I'm saying
in the year 1650 when like this would
what it would be you look like you look
honestly you you look like like a
Renaissance paint like I saw a picture
of what George Washington I don't know
if you could find it so you can put it
up now would look like if you were
president today and you look just like
that so I had a thing for Carmen Electra
and Jenny McCarthy and Pamela Anderson
of course same same oh interesting oh we
all agree we're the Dumb and Dumber of
tits back
so uh I uh and back then you know you
you it wasn't as easy to look at
pictures and videos and stuff you had to
download them and like wait for it to
yeah like fill in yeah almost like you
were like looking them up and down but
you had to go really slow yeah I found
them on hard copy
what yeah like on magazines and stuff
Philippines I was here already oh
where did you find those magazines I
mean like you would just basically
anywhere like your friends homes you
would tear them you would steal them
wherever you could find them steal them
yeah it was a thief
I was if you were a catfish I was a
thief were pictures of Pamela Anderson
anything I could get my little sticky
hands on Rick
there was a lot of theft in my younger
years yeah but okay printer
why I'm feeling a disconnect you're like
like these things these acknowledgments
that were not on the same page I really
think it'll I really think it'll help
the podcast
you know what
has bothered me in the past is the
morning after pill experience
it's a little too clinical it's a little
too boring it's a little too shameful
which is why I'm really glad that a
brand like Julie exists now because it's
fun it's taking the shame away from you
know a situation that
it sometimes is unavoidable
and Julie is an FDA approved morning
after pill that helps stop pregnancy
before it starts Julie stops your body
from releasing an egg using the same
active ingredient as plan b or other
morning after pills essentially Julie
works by preventing or delaying your
ovulation with no egg there's no
fertilization and therefore no pregnancy
and it's no risk to Future fertility if
you've ever had unprotected sex forgot
your birth control had a condom break or
you're just not sure we are so excited
to talk about this new company that is
giving emergency contraception a much
needed Rebrand Julie is an FDA approved
morning after pill that helps stop
pregnancy before it starts and honestly
at a time like we're living in right now
which is crazy the morning after pill is
more important than ever to just have it
on hand because I'm sorry but I don't
want a pregnancy that I don't want
right and it's legal in all 50 states
you do not need an ID prescription or
credit card to get it and Julie is not
just a morning after pill it's a morning
after pill brand that's working to
increase access to emergency
contraception for women across the
country Julie has a one-for-one donation
program and every time you purchase
Julie at a store or online the company
donates one pill to someone who needs it
and Julie partners with over 25
organizations across the country to
provide donations to those disproportion
disproportionately impacted by Health
inequities you can go to juliecare.co to
learn more or find Julia at your nearest
CVS Target or Walmart today that's
juliecare.co to learn more so kalila
you're the one that actually taught me
about athletic greens and you take it
every day and you mix it in water and it
helps with gut health
it helps I know for me I'm not a person
that can deal with calculating what
vitamins and minerals I need like the
fact that athletic greens does it all in
one place in one Fell Swoop is kind of
the only way I'm ever going to
be healthy yeah and it's it's easy it's
how I start my mornings I get
um eight ounces of water I um one scoop
of athletic greens I take my little
mochester stir it and sometimes I add a
little bit of ACV sometimes I don't
either way it tastes delicious and it
sort of just eliminates the guessing
game for me for the rest of the day well
it's hard for me to keep up with a
supplement routine that comes with a
bunch of different products also just
even knowing where to start with
supplements is even worse because I feel
like I'll scroll Tick Tock and I'll hear
all you need that's oh you need that
it's too much it's too confusing ag1 has
all the things you need they've done the
work the homework for you and I'm always
looking for life hacks which is why I've
come to love and Trust ag1 by athletic
greens the all-in-one formula makes it
easy for me to cover my nutritional
bases every day every scoop is packed
with 75 vitamins minerals and Whole Food
Source ingredients of the highest
quality that give me major benefits like
gut and mood support boosted energy an
even healthier looking skin hair and
nails and if you're looking for an
easier way to take supplements athletic
greens is giving you a free one-year
supply of vitamin D and five free travel
packs with your first purchase go to
athleticgreens.com Tuesday that's
athleticgreens.com Tuesday check it out
foreign
no you never gave me your guy I thought
I told you about a while ago I couldn't
wrong I need a guy can I have the guy
yeah um what does he do does he go
inside the mouth I would like that stuff
I love mouths I'm gonna tell you
something I I had a bad I had a bad jar
I went to my dentist I had a mold mate
it wasn't cheap it was like 600 bucks it
helped a little bit it's pretty cheap
for dental work it's not nothing
wait you had a was it a night guard it
was a night guard custom it wasn't
enough so then I ended up going to this
guy and I it's you It's Magic I've
referred a few people to him what does
he do
um it's a one-time fee which he'll tell
you after you meet with him to base this
in one retainer top bottom or both and
then that pays for five to six months
worth of treatment so he gives you the
retainer and then you go in for the
first month once a week and then you go
in as needed usually it'll be every few
weeks to every month for a bit it's
about 10 minutes of a little Physical
Therapy does a little movements
um he gives you exercises stretches he
keeps changing the guard and it's I
could oh I could just get a toothbrush
in for a while and now I'm I'm great I
think that so what I'm hearing is your
TMJ is from grinding because you need an
actual guard same with you same with you
grounded grinding clenching and stress
yeah
I don't your first special it'd still be
my next
I don't grind
what do you do I don't grind I I just I
do this like facial flex but I don't
necessarily clench either because my
dentist says he doesn't see a lot of
evidence you can usually see in your
teeth and your back teeth if you have a
lot of grinding and clenching well I
have enough evidence just by the
conversation we're having wait can I ask
you a question do you feel like if
somebody came in and gave you like a
really great amazing jaw massage that
you would get really horny
um
probably okay any type of Massage
[Laughter]
um but that's how he sounds great I just
don't know if I would benefit from a
mouth guard that's what's happening
what's what's happening you're you're
clenching you're you're overworking the
muscle also there's a decent chance that
it's it's not even and one size
overcompensating you might be chewing
uneven I think mine is stemming from my
neck it is here it is because I did go
to a pain doctor specifically who does
like TMJ stuff and he was like oh all of
your stuff is from your neck and it
moves forward you go like this
maybe fixed how do you feel now not
better
I realized that weed was helping with my
jaw and my constipation I quit weed and
now those problems are back so don't so
you don't smoke weed anymore and now you
can't poop well it's just it's harder
again
my gastrointestinal issue but aren't you
on a magnesium citrate I just started so
because I quit weed I was looking for an
alternative to help with relaxing and
bowel movements and so I got those
gummies the calm gummies which are
magnesium citrate but you take magnesium
I take magnesium but I take like stuff
that actually absorbs into the body so I
don't know about the gummies is mine
wait mine's not good I I don't know if
it works for you it works for you sister
only takes medicine and candy form what
was the penicillin chocolates that you
were taking when you had strep
was it palacino brownies
we'll be right back
so it's not good what I have I don't
know if it works for you are you pooping
a lot
the world of flies around her while
we're waiting outside that's where am I
wrong those were there when I got there
yes they were big fans of hers Esther
actually has a really great audience of
flies and rats the flying rat tour that
could be your next one would your
parents go
take a lot of magnesium's complex I take
a complex that has a lot of things
including citrate but then I when I'm
feeling in the mood and I often am I'll
take some free plug Mag 07 magnesium
oxide and that's the that's that fills
the intestines with water so you just
drink a lot of water with it and it
helps flush out the reason that I those
either of those magsite and mag oxide
does not work for me is because I
already have gi problems and so I cannot
have anything that even like um
irritates it or causes frequency so I do
the glistenate one now that's moderate
cholesterol is a moderate magnesium
but I of all the ones that have worked
well on like my heart palpitations and
like my
um little eye twitches is the glistenate
it's changed my life what is it doing to
your body do you know
um I think it's just I don't know what
it is but I don't know how it directly
potential nervous system lets things
relax you know our intestines are just a
little fibers going to work and when
they're stressed but jazz hands
but my heart issue like my I have like
an electrical conductivity issue in my
heart and for some reason I don't get as
many palpitations so it works for me
highly recommend wow okay so we're all
on the Magnesium plug right now Rick
you're in
um
I'm asking you this because I'm on a a
journey
um a solo Journey myself but you're not
so solo anymore these days I am I am in
a relationship at the moment uh for uh I
was we were talking before about like
when you get out of a relationship then
how long do you stay single is this what
we're getting toward yep I typically am
single for a while while between don't
date much between and that's a very
intentional thing you do it's
intentional yes but not intentional like
something I'm trying
um the analogy I gave is like like you
try not to eat sugar you you want sugar
but you're like you're not eating the
sugar so it's not like I want to be
dating but like I think it's best for me
I fortunately I believe don't have the
desire to yeah but that's good are you
hooking up with people I mean I I have
and I you know I'm not I'm I think I
have a great analogy let's hear it ask
me if I drink
why do I have to ask you I'm so sorry
you're right I I I shouldn't have asked
you to to help and play along okay or do
you drink not really no I'm not sober
like I'll have a drink but usually no oh
so women are like a drink to you it's
like having a drink
in the analogy I'm not drawn to that um
like if like I'm somewhere and I'm in
the mood for a drink I'm not gonna be
like I can't do this right but I'm not
like actively seeking I'm not actively
seeking I'm not like hooking up all the
time no uh nor am I looking for it if
you leave the door open should someone
yeah really light you up in that way
yeah I do think that that door isn't
open wide for the first while after a
breakup how long
are you somebody that when the breakup
happens you are you are grieving the
breakup in that moment or are you a
distraction guy no no grieving oh see
that's great I think that's why
admittingly I do look for distraction
not with other women but like with weed
movies but no I'm grieving I'm I'm
grieving I've noticed this in you I
think which I relate to tell me if I'm
wrong but like when I get dumped
you've gotten dumped
[Music]
I and similar to what you're saying it's
like I feel every feeling I'm so sad I
like there is no escaping the feelings
like I'm not the like I feel like I see
with guys typically which I'm it's
interesting to hear you're not like that
well I'm not a guy I'm a man
um they want to hook up hook up you know
and they don't feel it and I always am
like God I I've always felt like yeah
I've yeah it's more guys than girls I
feel like girls move on quicker not a
chance I I would if there was even a way
to distract me from my pain I would do
it but it's like there's no I can't even
think of like [__] someone else would
make it exponentially worse for me doing
this traveling anything I cannot escape
from my grief in that moment I can't
think of a single thing to distract me
from my grief like I am fully in a state
of Calamity and I like it that's a good
t-shirt in a state of cult but you do
kalila instead I'm fully in a state of
oh my Instagram handle is Calamity yeah
yeah that's what you just did to me oh
really girls are like drinks oh really
and let me guess that women are the hair
because they're hairy and ugly and men
are the tortoise because they have big
dicks
where this is a big
I'm getting to a point that it is
beneficial to everyone at this table
which I think slow and steady wins the
race I think feeling it and and feeling
the pain at first and taking your time
with it I think in the long run that is
better and healthier and I still don't
know if those people that got over me
really fast if they were okay there's a
decent chance that they were not I don't
mean this in a nice way interested in
you to begin with
do you know what I'm saying like maybe
like you were around and because you you
need that validation so much it was easy
does that make sense no this is actually
a very big theme in my life that I'm
realizing that I have sought male
validation but it is meaningless because
men have no standards now that is that
is that is an okay way for you to digest
that it is not
um sustainable to feel that way by by
making fun of men and I get that I think
men are pigs and if God exists she's a
woman however
I have nothing against men I think men
and women are equal equally bad and
equally good I think women are a little
better I think you're smarter they're
stronger what they could do with their
bodies what they have to put go through
with the patriarchy listen I'm a man
just like the next guy but like I am so
impressed with women all the time I
think women are so that's weird that
you're even going out of your way to say
that it's like out of my way formal
really sort of like wait is that why you
were a girl in the chat rooms
huh
I never thought about that way but there
is a chance that because you know like
chat rooms were a place where you could
be social from away for the first time
and that made it easier for me I was
trying to be like you know how like when
your kids wear superhero costumes which
I did like that was me being a superhero
my mom
fake
[Laughter]
my mom's a superhero fake
we can make jokes about it that's fine
we don't have to get serious about it
no I just I just I grew up with very
strong women and that's why that's why
you're attracted to models
did you hear my joke no right put on the
[__] headphones you pig I'm sorry I'm
agreeing to do this podcast because
there are some I've been doing some fun
little things everybody agrees I'm sure
it's certain those are that racist my
brain is still in Asia oh you're right I
shouldn't put my finger but I am Asian
I'm allowed to do this I'm not no you
know why you're not allowed to do it
tell me I don't know why I think you
should be allowed to do micromanage in
Asian about being Asian my only year is
not allowed to there's no rules
everyone's allowed to do whatever they
want here
do you feel not allowed certain things
yeah I don't feel like I'm allowed to
have my Nuance picked up on because you
don't wear headphones
we don't wear headphones
correct correct
so your mom is your hero you love your
mommy you were a mommy on the chat in
the chat rooms oh I was a mommy
mommy what would you say hey hey pretty
boys show me your [__] [__] and I'll
eat your ass no really what would you
say show me a [__] I'll eat your ass why
I'm just joking
um I I really don't remember the things
I would say but I do remember I learned
a slash
L cyber question mark do you want the
privilege I never got to partake in
it makes so much sense that you and I
both did this in our parents basement it
wasn't sexual I I mean there might have
been some subconscious thing that I
didn't recognize but I do remember the
feeling of like this doesn't feel sexual
I I I know I'm lying but I didn't even
feel like I was doing something wrong it
really felt like intuitive
it just felt experimental like what is
this first of all experimental into the
world of chat rooms which was new at the
time anyway and then doing something
that I could never do elsewhere I don't
remember why originally it was a woman I
don't know if I was always a woman it
also wasn't always like like it's like
it wasn't cyber necessarily age sex
location that's what that's the how you
doing back in the day it wasn't even
trying to say did you put a could you
put a picture up of yourself no you'd
have to you have to send it to them and
it was always send to receive s2r so
yeah
like my growth is stunted because I
never got to do that absolutely right
yeah if you pretended you were a man in
a chat room when you were 10 you would
be way better off most normal most
people I know I don't think did what we
I think there's a reason that I don't
want to throw this person under the bus
although I don't think they care
um
but uh a very good friend of mine did
the same thing and also pretended he was
a girl okay that is weird to me because
I why did you guys pretend you were
girls can we get anywhere with it yeah
well I don't know that I I never thought
about this I'm hypothesizing live on the
take what's this I was going to say the
take your shoes off podcast what is it
called trash Tuesday
maybe it was easier to talk to a guy as
a girl than it would be to talk to a
girl as a guy that makes sense probably
more people in that room were guys now
that that's not a conscious thing I
remember but like maybe I did both and I
found that like there was more
interaction from guys and it wasn't like
I'm stroking my [__] dick no it was
just like oh where are you from it was
it was relatively wholesome
it was sexual but it wasn't physically
sexual like the content for me was
sexual but I didn't have any sexual
feelings at all at all no in fact like
you didn't go through people until
you're 33 right
wait so I for me it was phone sex lines
if we called the 900 numbers people like
you and your family well they weren't
necessarily sex lines they were called
party lines and so you would hear
someone's voice just on voice alone and
then you would say hello if you did not
like the way they sound sounded you
would hit a number and then they would
go to the next person it's kind of like
I'll better help you could switch your
therapists at any time very quickly yes
so
um
yeah
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
getting to know yourself can be a
lifelong process especially because we
are always growing and changing hello
look at me I'm a different person every
single day
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding because
sometimes we don't know what we want we
don't know why we react the way we do
until we talk through things with
someone who's there to listen and better
help connects you with a licensed
therapist who can take you on that
journey of self-discovery from wherever
you are
I have to say that without therapy I
would not be able to be in a healthy
relationship I would not be able to have
a healthy working relationship with you
and Annie and I just
I can't imagine my life would be in the
gutter without therapy same and you guys
it's entirely online it's designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with a
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
discover your potential with betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday so I
don't know about you but organizing
money is
a challenge
and I'm definitely someone who will sign
up for any subscription and forget about
it and that is why rocket money has been
such an asset to my life because rocket
money is a personal finance app that
finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions they forget about and
chances are you're one of them like for
instance I had this insect finder it's
so weird and I have this other anime app
that I didn't know my niece had
downloaded onto my phone and I have
paying like an obnoxious amount every
year I have so many streaming services
it's like it's dark
rocket money will quickly and easily
find your subscriptions for you and for
any you don't want to pay for anymore
just hit cancel and Rocket money will
cancel it for you it's that easy rocket
money also helps you manage all of your
finances in one place and automatically
categories categorize your expenses so
you can easily track your budget in real
time and also get alerted if anything
looks off which is important over three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to 720 a
year stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
um could we try this out could I call
and you be who you're talking about and
you be the voice
I'm gonna call uh this party line
because you guys do go back you recreate
my party line experience fine but if I
switch we're gonna go to you yeah and
you and also give Esther a little bit of
notes like what should Esther know like
what types of voices give her some ideas
of what be yourself be who you were back
then no but she's the part she's at work
these girls have a certain no no no
that's not how it worked it wasn't a sex
line it was a phone number everyone
could call to meet people
yeah it was basically like a Tinder
we're both we're both trying to talk to
somebody it's not like I'm calling to
talk to a pardon the joke a hot girl
right right correct gotcha
all right let's try it will you do the
ring sound effect please okay but do it
like this
hello hi hi
I'm sorry hi hi
how old are you
for 30. same
um
do you like TV
are you okay yeah yeah switch
it's like next you remember that show
yeah yeah no it's like Chat Roulette
didn't you guys do that what is that
you know what it is I know what it is
okay it's like
I'm sure if it's roulette then there's a
chat yeah it's like a video and then you
keep clicking it and it's like like
you're matched up with random people but
a lot of times people would be like
they'd be out with their schwants
became very unwholesome oh a lot of
penises you guys remember hotter and is
it hot or not yeah I would never go near
that why you don't think people would
find you beautiful
I don't know I don't want to know yes
you do they won't so
um it's uh yeah it's a site that just
like matches you up like live you get to
talk to somebody oh me it still exists
it's Omegle now shout out to Harry Mack
by the way who's a rapper who does it on
Amigo all the time and just random
people come up hello and he goes he's
unbelievable do you guys know Harry Mack
he's
he's unbelievable it's actually probably
it's one of my favorite podcasts I've
done was him on mine but he's so good
and he'll like ask somebody for three
random words and he'll freestyle and
it's like
good but then you see these people who
are just people in their bedrooms
reacting there's something very cool
about matching up with people I just
think people take advantage and become
very dirty and inappropriate because
they have the internet you mean like
what exactly what we did when we were
children in chat rooms yeah maybe but
but again I I
wasn't I wasn't TR I wasn't
and it seemed like you weren't either
like being dirty what we were doing was
weird but like it was I was I was a kid
and I was experimenting like what is it
like talking to guys and girls and how
do other guys talk to girls I want to
hear it and it wasn't like me showing
the penis or trying to get pictures of a
penis or a vagina would you try to it
wasn't sexual I definitely wanted to
exchange photos but I agree that it
wasn't sexual weirdly like it was more
experimenting in the world yeah that was
not my experience and the party lines I
was always reaching for my toothbrush to
stick into my I would get into yeah I
don't know what you were gonna say to
stick it to your mouth to brush your
teeth
it was brushing something wait what age
as a teenager
not as a 10 year old but by the time I
was like 15 16 and you know this was I
didn't have a computer so I and I would
get super super horny and I would just
want to hear someone's voice across the
line and I would we would just
[Music]
talk dirty and I would find my
toothbrush and use it to masturbate
which is the only thing like I I could I
I had that was of a certain length how
far do you need don't you only need to
to go in a few inches only if you're
right
right thank you for that Rick all of my
nerves are right at the entrance if you
go any deeper it's like no man's lineup
yeah you like the type of guys you do go
ahead did you get to a Finish Line
yeah and I would feel extreme Foot
Locker
in the Foot Locker in a Foot Locker why
is that what you did
I I obviously you were you'd like to
masturbate in a Finish Line I was just
curious other places we'll be right back
yeah but I was I was a really
really literally
brush my G-spot because it was the
bristle end and I would do things like I
would find like the basically dug out
and I would have sex with who I would
anywhere I could find any weird cut
of I would have sex with no fantasize
ever about masturbating with an electric
toothbrush because of what toothbrushes
mean to you and follow-up question do
you think this is why you have TMJ
um I think that um
I don't use any sexual toys anymore
because I don't like to keep upping the
bar for my you know to come instead of
growing like last night last night I
swear to you guys this is so
embarrassing
it took me six seconds
to come I swear to you it was I was
watching the show beef and there was
this really hot scene with Ali Ali Wong
and um this other Asian guy again hot
Asians and I was like oh [__] it's like
I'm I'm so jet lag what am I gonna do to
put myself to sleep do you have a clip
click after a [__]
so I swear to you like I shocked myself
I put my hand on my [__] and that was
it really and I was like oh that's fine
you had my address I know we are so
close oh yeah you didn't tell me where
you were but isn't that incredible I
needed nothing well you're not
desensitized by all of the Machinery
right and I never want to be because you
use toothbrushes on your vagina would
you consider maybe you don't clench I
don't use your brushes in my vagina
anymore Rick I was doing a jaw Kegel
joke and if you had on your headphones
this wouldn't be a [__] problem would
it you think yeah do you I don't yeah I
think a jaw Kegel joke would be a
problem headphones or not I don't think
it makes sense do you uh do you jerk off
yeah tell me again did you floss your
[__]
did I floss my [__]
no because that would cut my [__] oh I
just thought you like really small and
thin penises go ahead
what's this whole printer story that's
going to be really worth it
well I just want to let you become aware
of the condescension in your voice
because that makes me not want to tell
the story anymore
they make I'm very vulnerable let me
provide you a safe place safe space Rick
looking to look into my eyes
I want to hear the prince's story
it's more of an anecdote
so there I am
Doom I think I I wanted pictures of them
because Carmen uh Jenny McCarthy Jenny
McCarthy Carmen Electra and um and
Pamela Anderson were the women Arnold
Schwarzenegger Sylvester Stallone and
Van Damme were the men I was obsessed
with muscles wait
um sly Van Damme and Schwarzenegger was
King but I mean Schwarzenegger really
Stallone Van Damme oh yeah
oh yeah I thought I was I really loved
obviously as a kid superheroes and
muscles were very cool and and like I
wanted to be that and
um I became obsessed with Arnold I don't
remember what maybe T2 but then I went
back to all the other stuff barbarians
and such isn't this interesting that you
probably saw the mostly guys here's your
big shot get the girls so that's what
you wanted to be but meanwhile me and
kalila are both examples of women here
who are not into the big muscly guys
well what's that about interesting
interesting because I'm so attracted to
you that what a bummer however
um if I weren't so allergic to flies and
rats I would maybe give you a shot
I like muscles because muscles were cool
I still feel that way I mean you look at
you look at athletes like specifically
cool basketball players not athletes
just basketball players and they just
like they're builds it's just I don't
know they're like superheroes but I for
me it's not the muscles I like agility
then you'd love me
um because I I like them I like I said
you know I like them a little thick I
like I like a belly but it's all about
whether or not someone is able and
coordinated because that to me
translates have you seen my my character
piece I am phenomenal available now on
YouTube I have I have see how agile I
was you are so so athletic surprising
can I ask a question one sec
should people check it out should your
fan base check it out what you do go to
my Channel at Rick lasting just YouTube
phenomenal when I think about it look at
me I'm undressing stop that's
inappropriate you're right you're in a
relation now I'm so sorry I was trying
to do that what's it like I'm sorry has
he been here the whole time
yeah last night he kept walking out of
the room and he'd look at me like nice
to meet you dude
um what is it like if you're so agile
I'm so sorry sir one second you were
talking about how athletic I am yeah and
I liked um what was the title of your
I'm phenomenal I am you are phenomenal
Rick thank incredibly phenomenal and you
know we just had our 200th episode of
the take your shoes off podcast
congratulations the last time I was here
I didn't tell people about my podcast so
oh um they know
well what is it like though Jesus
I'm so sorry
take off that what are you wearing
take it off
we get some more sweat under our picture
oh never mind I thought they were drying
up go ahead okay I wouldn't progress
report
not so bad
okay
no you're so agile but yet it seems like
you really need like go ahead go ahead
spit in your mouth and you're laughing
too soon because you anticipated
something being funny try it again it
seems like you really
really you know how agile you are but
you really need the external validation
for it what's that about you're talking
to me like I'm a puppy
James like you're really agile but you
need chicken
chicken
will you Google search Green Tongue and
see what that means I think you should
get that checked honestly
do you go to doctors are you afraid that
they're gonna find everything
honestly honestly you're a monster I
look at you and I'm whenever I'm with
you I'm reminded I have a good time with
you because of how funny I am and you
enjoy it you're a monster look at me
you're a monster thank you it's your
monster dude that's thank you for
plugging my Instagram at Esther monster
oh my God how many I had no idea this at
Rick Glassman
no but seriously and I I want you to
know that this is coming from no I
understand what you're saying and I can
answer that because there is truth to it
okay first of all I'm not hiding behind
it there is a very strong level of irony
I come on I plug better help or
mattresses or my other videos or my
podcast I do think it's fun to
self-promote however why am I choosing
to do that yes I have actually what I am
saying has nothing to do with
self-promotion no no no no no no I know
what you're here let me let me get this
out or if you had your oh your phones on
um
but why is it that I'm like I'm choosing
to promote these things and I'm not
going to get too much into it just
because I've talked about it again it
has nothing to do with you personally
I'm getting I'm getting it was about you
seeking validation from her calling you
ad jobs I don't know if you maybe if you
put your headphones on you'd hear me
okay I'm getting there I hear you great
why is it that these are the things
agile
oh sure could we get her something what
do you want shrimp what do you normally
eat can we get her some shrimp and some
type of a milkshake it doesn't matter
which kind
I I uh started playing basketball late
in high school and that's when I first
started getting friends when I first
started getting confidence when I first
started feeling included oh this is sad
so they're um it's actually beautiful I
understand why it said you have yet to
be included I uh no it's not true you
have a podcast now that people now know
you right you're single how come you're
you stop doing your solo podcast I
didn't I still have it it's called my
pleasure
gotcha people watch it they listen it's
only audio the audio number is good
they're pretty good I'm happy yes oh
good I I
um didn't really have friends and then I
started playing basketball and just by
the idea of us having a common goal
which is practicing at this time to win
yeah I was part of a team and there is a
camaraderie with teams
um I talked about this I think on
Sickler's podcast recently but I feel
the same way about comedy like
even though we're all doing our own
thing especially we can't wait till you
land the plane how we we're like this
team and like we're showing up at The
Comedy Store we had our improv tube like
you feel included totally so my family
yeah and like yeah and accepted and
we're all different but like you want
people around and you offer value I'm
making you laugh that makes me like
shared interests yes yes so basketball
was the first time I really experienced
that so there is a part of me that
though I'm aware of it it still exists
where I had this identity
that
that I'm good at basketball I want
people to know I'm back go to basketball
when I would go into gyms and people
knew who I was I wouldn't have to wait
to play they would we got glassmen and
that always felt so good one I get to
play but two like am I cool like totally
like me and I feel the same way about
dance I grew up dancing and I was I
was quite good yeah but uh if we're
going where I think you're going which I
hope you are because I don't know where
else you could be going so when kalila
says oh you're athletic there is a part
of me through jokes but it's it's
inspired and true where it's like I want
people to know I'm not just some [__]
Jewish goof who's always doing like oh
oh you know okay I'm cool man so there
is part of me that's like selling cool
yeah but see that's so you didn't answer
you just sort of confirmed what I said
why do you need that external validation
for example me I know I'm an amazing
dancer that's why you keep bringing it
up no no no it's your fourth time don't
I don't actually just did it I don't
need people it's an amazing dancer I
don't need people to tell me I I feel it
I practice it I know it yeah but it
seems like you really need to be told no
it came up organically but maybe I'm
wrong maybe I have a blind spot okay but
I'm just curious do you really feel that
way about yourself or do you need the
validation from the extra validation
from that okay I never needed them that
that there are out of the things that I
could argue I would need validation from
that was that wouldn't be one of them
because that what do I need validation
for
um I
we all need validation it's okay none of
us would be sitting here if we didn't
but I think that we've seen you move
and I have seen your your full agile
self also I think that
um I'm agile you really are that good
Rick that I I don't think maybe you need
as much validation there because I think
you know I really I really I also am
like consciously trying to not sound
defensive to let upstairs feel heard
um Esther uh but no I don't think so
but it does make me feel good it does
make me feel good like when other people
on podcast talk about me as a basketball
player or even just someone says Rick I
heard that there is a absolutely part of
me where I go I'm glad you know it's a
separate part of you that you're not you
know showing on like yes daily I think
in the same way that you're like oh my
God Esther can dance yeah like and you
are a very good dancer you are
thank you I feel the exact same way when
people are like no you know she's a
swimmer she does this yeah her whole
life being in the water I'm like I have
I did totally it's so amazing in the
water I totally agree and I think we all
there's no way we don't all love
compliments I get it I am just
personally on my own journey of learning
about my validation needs and thank you
for sharing with everybody yes and so
and so
what I'm learning is that I think people
who are truly whole and confident and
have self-esteem and self-worth they
don't really need compliments about
things that they feel whole with may I I
think people that are fully whole or
even on their way in a lot and pretty
enlightened don't feel the need to let
other people know how incomplete they
are now I think that's a projection that
you're doing because you're a miserable
person
and I'm digging in for for podcast
reasons I also think there's something
very important and this has been my
journey for about six years now of
understanding what you are both how you
sell yourself why you sell yourself and
what it is that you're selling I love
that and accepting that thing and there
are things about me that they are what
they are am I perfect I think so however
some people might think that's
subjective there are things about me
that like this is the thing I am I will
like when people think I'm I'm a good
athlete it will make me feel good if I
were completely enlightened and I didn't
need external validation I would need
that but then I also wouldn't get the
fun connection and that fun feeling I am
somebody who is has both insecurities
and also very little if any Shame about
them this is the thing that I am
truthfully I love who I am and
it feels good to be it feels good to be
accepted I mean like validation from an
audience of people laughing at you and
clapping like recognizing that is how
you know what jokes work absolutely I
actually and I have talked about this on
podcasts and so bad at that because I
don't understand what people are
thinking
what do you mean
I don't when I do a show and I hear
people laughing I hear it I don't know
if they really think it's funny or what
they think is funny oh well I can I I
often especially in the starting early
days of my comedy I never knew what was
going to be funny well you nothing
[Laughter]
but is that what you mean or what I'm
saying is and again I'm feeling a little
insecure about talking about this too
much because I've talked about it on
mine and others but I am I am not very
in touch with how other people receive
me
even if they're laughing and doing this
whatever I think about me is what I'm
that's the only thing that I believe
well that's good it's great it has
gotten in my way a little bit because
there there is a social contract that
you have where
for example I bust your balls a lot
we've had conversations off podcasts
about this where I've asked you and you
have told me this is fun like we're
having a good time
do you understand what I'm saying like
yeah if people didn't know us right and
you just took jump cuts of the things I
say to you and not see your reaction and
not the engagement I could look mean
now I could be the same exact thing and
you being turned off now I'm mean or I
could be this thing and you laughing and
people really love it I'm still the same
person but people are looking at the
reaction shots so it is important for me
to see how I'm being received and I do
have a hard time that is true
understanding that yes but I do think
there's a superpower in the other
version of it because a lot of the times
you'll see people uh dictate their
content
oh I'm surprised you didn't tell me to I
have the worst posture she has great
posture they'll dictate what they say
they'll they'll Pander and I think when
you have the skill that you have so
honed in on which is knowing only caring
about what you think and feel which is
what I'm working on as a creative person
is like what do I really feel as opposed
to I don't want to do just because oh
people like this one thing like I want
to do what I want to do so I do think
that's very valuable skill there's
something that you said that it's a
semantic but I want to change you said
not caring about what other people think
I don't believe in that that's not a
real thing [__] what other people think
it doesn't matter what other people
think
um it does matter what other people
think there's a difference between what
I'm about to say and that what other
people think does matter I just don't
prioritize what they think over what I
do does that make sense right like it's
kind of the same well here's here's why
it's different and I'll give another
analogy with stand-up and fear I used to
be very I still get scared I used to get
very scared to go up on stage and there
was a moment where I had this
realization where I accepted oh that's
what I do I get scared and instead of
pretending I'm not scared and you know
like wiping off my palms or psyching
myself up and just like instead of that
I have accepted that fear is not only
okay it's a guarantee and I'm just not
going to let it control my decisions
totally so what that means is am I
scared no [__] that I don't care no
absolutely I'm scared but because I know
that and I've accepted it it doesn't
need to be in the front of my mind and I
could still be present why I use that
exact same thing when I'm sad about
something instead of saying don't be sad
I'm so mad at myself for being sad I'm
like I'm sad about this that's what you
were saying about grieving and going
feeling your feelings yes yes yeah so I
feel that way about not but the idea of
not caring what other people think I
think that's that language gets in the
way of how you see personal interactions
because if I am trying to get myself to
this confident place and I'm like I
don't care what you think I'm not going
to go in this conversation and not care
what you think I do care and I'm
interested but it's not going to control
my my self-identity I think you were
right that it's semantics because it's
kind of the same thing we're talking
about which is like when I post I posted
a clip yesterday from our podcast saying
that my sexual fantasy is to be a Jewish
girl and a Nazi saves me to have sex
with me and so many people are like this
is [__] up you're wrong for posting
this
and I like my attitude going in has to
be like this is I set a sexual fantasy
of mine and I needed the world to know
and if you and I don't care that but
here's on top of that because I read or
I read Esther perel's book yeah which
one it's basically like your politics
and your standing beliefs about life all
the things have nothing to do with your
sexual Kinks they are fully separate
because she has a lot of patients who go
in who are basically what anyone would
call a feminazi but love
have rape Kinks have the most [__] up
I bet you there's a through line to
those too there's a suppression but
there is no through maybe don't say like
like like when when when guys or girls
go to only guys only girls school
and like they're not allowed to go out
and drink and they have to be home by
yeah like there's there's oh there's a
there's a suppression of things that
they may have wanted to at least
experiment with Like Us in chat rooms
that they the pendulum swings the other
way pretty far I think that like a lot
of priests who aren't allowed to do
stuff right but I'm just saying like as
well with with priesthood it's different
because there is a real suppression
there but for someone who is you know
not suppressing suppressing their sexual
anything I would well Ester perel
basically says this that like you those
compartments in your brain can live very
very separately and one doesn't have
anything to do with the other and I
would I would agree with that because
even me being some somebody who's been
sexually assaulted like the the weird
like you would think that my body would
reject the experience or reject the
thought of anything that would suggest
yeah you'd think if you were sexually
assaulted you would like white men
correct but my Kinks do not correlate
the way with my trauma like almost at
all subconsciously in no way sex sex is
just in the spirit of play I can fully
take myself to a place where I am just
fully sexual that is not like there are
no strings to the other parts of my
brain or my morality or my value system
at all I can I can confidently say that
and I would also say that my that Kink
that I have is probably just because Ray
finds was super hot in Schindler's List
and he was a Nazi and it's like if
Spielberg didn't want me to be attracted
to Nazis he should have cast someone
uglier
that's a good t-shirt thank you I'm not
joking
Spielberg didn't want me to be attracted
to Nazis you would have cast somebody
uglier yes you would have cast me wait
that wasn't Liam Neeson no Liam Neeson
was Oscar Schindler Ray fines was the
evil spoiler alert right right right not
as funny as I remember I rewatched it I
think Dumb and Dumber is funnier
um but I do like what you say I think
that you should lead with that kind of
fearless
um I've just yeah I've just decided and
I wonder if you relate to this I'm very
curious actually because you seem like I
can't tell which where you won't land on
this but like
I can't do this thing that I've signed
up to do if I'm not going to be so open
and free and like freedom to upset
people freedom to express myself
honestly like that's what I need for
this to work otherwise I've done it the
other way for years where I'm hiding and
holding back it's that doesn't help me
and it's not artistically or creatively
fulfilling now does that mean I don't
give a [__] what other people think
a little
me not not so crudely yeah but well
because you're choosing to share to
these people that you don't care what
they think so that that's not real
well I'm you wouldn't be sharing it so
it's what I guess it is the semantics of
what you said I'm prioritizing what I
think and and those semantics are
relevant we talked about this on one of
the one of the the um tiger bellies that
I did with you guys but I
I really believe that the language we
use to ourselves
changes the way we see the world I agree
and and that idea of and the example I I
think I gave there was instead of I have
to do something I get to do something I
have to come to New York and do this
podcast today I get to do this like this
idea of like certain language literally
instills gratitude and excitement and
positivity and not
I think caring what people think is such
an important good thing at least for
them to be understood even if you don't
agree with them you know that's a really
good point you're making because I've
kind of like started thinking about the
types of people who deem themselves
truth tellers and brutally honest and
I'm like I think that those are the most
cruel people on Earth because I think
they enjoy being honest as much as they
enjoy being brutal and cruel and and if
if you're somebody that I love and care
about I'm gonna tell a few lies I'm
going to mince my words I'm going to say
certain things depending on how you're
appearing in front of me and your mood
like I mean I'm not gonna lie about big
things right but like people who just
are just so like like piercing all the
[__] time I'm like no do you not care
about like the persons like if like if
my sister is having a bad day like I'm
going to
dance around
like her sensitivities that day because
I care about her and I don't want to
make it worse and if that involves like
you know a white liar I'm gonna do it I
don't believe in like brutal honesty at
all because I think it's just that it's
brutal I don't believe it's as binary as
that and I have a strong take on what
you're saying but before I do um would
you like to uh use the bathroom or
something I'm okay for now thank you
yeah you're projecting you yes pupus
okay no no I'm okay
um so uh no go poop really I'm okay I
was really because I was talking and
then you were talking and then I was
gonna go back and I just want to include
one more time
um Ethel
um so
I do think that people
um use honesty sometimes and really
believe this that well I'm being honest
so it's almost like I'm allowed to do it
I really think they believe it for
whatever reason I don't think that
matters they believe it I think there is
so much value in always being honest now
always I don't mean you're a robot yes
people lie there's a spectrum of it and
what makes a lie but like but if there's
a spectrum of LIE there's also a
spectrum of honesty then right
but I'm saying by spectrum of light I
mean like you said lying about big
things or little things things that
don't really matter or like things that
are not necessarily lies like if I could
tell that you don't want to eat now and
I'm a little hungry and you ask you
hungry I'm like no I'm okay because I
know that you want to keep like there
are things shorthand but there are also
ways of being honest tactfully
both in the way you do it and the timing
of it for example if your sister's in a
bad mood and she says how was my how did
my dress look tonight you don't have to
say it was the most beautiful dress in
the world you could say you are so
beautiful and uh you know whatever like
you're so beautiful I had such a great
time blah blah blah and then later on if
you think it offers her value to not
wear that thing again if you think you
you could bring it up at a time where
she could hear it
I you're confused
I I don't have a strong point of view
yet but in this example I'm like is it a
little gaslighty though to if she knows
she feels looks bad and you're saying
you look great that's why I'm saying the
tactics so if she if she says how does
this check this out if you don't like my
outfit I don't right it's a good example
thank you and I say how's my outfit you
could tell that I need I'm feeling a
little something where I need a little
reassurance right okay I could say Rick
you look without talking about my outfit
you could say Rick you look you look
handsome today your posture is good you
asked about your outfit that's what I'm
saying it there's a there's a there's a
political way around it but then if
you're doing if we're doing this I'm
gonna and I'm you I'm gonna be like oh I
asked about my outfit all right let's do
it okay and I'm I value honesty very
very very very very much because I need
it I need it because I didn't always get
it and I didn't know I don't know when
people are lying I don't know if they
even know when they're lying I value it
and I do look at information
above my ego where I can if it triggers
me it triggers me but like I want the
information so doing that I do it the
other way and there are jokes and
they're silly and let's do a real
example of it if I see that you need
some validation which I know you don't
then here's how it would go so go ahead
and ask me the question you have to ask
me
um
but like to read real because I'm gonna
be real okay so you could be president
doesn't have to be a scene just ask me
now okay do you uh
you think that I'm attractive
before I answer that great one good one
I want to know what your intention like
are you being playful or no I'm like do
do you think like if Dave dumped me that
like I could get someone good no
okay
so you didn't do the thing I did the
thing and I made a point and I made a
strong one
you laugh at that stuff all the time but
you were you were looking for something
else
I know with you if you were really
asking me something the way I would do
it were to be a little bit fighty and a
little playful to make sure that our
conversations were authentic because
otherwise tell me what you think of this
ask me the question again do you think
I'm attractive you're beautiful
do you believe me no right
[Laughter]
I'm so confused yeah I think we're
dancing around this in a way there was a
little bit of play that didn't work and
up that's I'll take full blame look I
just think I guess the point I was
making is this you could always be
honest
um you can yeah but I I think that there
are people as of late who are like
I know what you're saying I'm a truth
teller that's those are people that
think hey it ain't mean if it's true
yeah no [__] you it's yes it is it's
your intention isn't to be kind your
intention is to add to prove how honest
you are and that's selfish and you're
getting off on knowing that and feeling
smarter and holier than that and also in
you right and I'm also I am basically
people who have to announce their asset
like I always say like beware of
declarations if you have to announce
your asset there's probably something
that isn't honest can you give an
example of what that is I'm a great
dancer
like it's like I guess I just have a
really bad experience with one of my um
uh younger relationships in my 20s where
the guy was always like had to announce
like I I'm not this or I'm not this I am
this and I'm like we'll just be that
show me that because then it was like oh
like and later I found out he was not
any of those things well that's the
casting thing that's the I I I have a
narrative of what I I want to be seen a
certain way yeah that's what people and
and but now people are saying well like
they're I had even the word truth teller
is very like it I don't sends a chill
down my spine and I'm like yeah because
defining it yeah I'm like oh you're that
and I'm not that like shut the [__] up
right like you have to and so now now
you are like the gospel because you
announced yourself as a truth teller
because what like maybe I'm somebody who
who is you know
not as like like I said like I do dance
around people's like feelings I'm really
good at dancing around people's feelings
show us
but I know what you're saying if I I'm
like hey like how do I look and you're
like honestly I think you could put on
something better that I do appreciate
yeah you want to know if you have a
picture
you look you want somebody to tell you
you have something but you don't have
them do it like oh
like oh you know you do it like hey
and I think it's a beautiful Booker but
you might want to get rid of it I will
say that when I was in my early 20s I
had a friend once who was like I'm a
good person and I remember walking away
from that being like confused because I
was like I've never heard someone say to
me that they're a good person dude
and then I was like I feel like that
feels weird it's so weird
I talk about this on stage
I the I this is a microcosm for other
things but chivalry and what you're
supposed to do on dates or early dating
the idea of getting the car door for a
girl if we're coming from the passenger
side
yeah I'll you know I'll get the door
we're right here whatever but if we're
coming from the driver's side the idea
that of me going around the car with you
to open the door for you feel so
manipulative because it's this is me
trying to show you I'm a good guy which
by the way I am and this isn't the
reason and I don't want to get this door
if you told me it makes me feel good to
get the door sure I'll do it but for me
to pretend that this is what I do I
actually love that I I agree with that
your goodness does not hinge on whether
or not you're gonna
um you know swing the door hinges so
yeah is that the pun yes but that's the
thing like there are things you're
supposed to do and the idea of what
you're supposed to do
supposed to whatever whatever the thing
might be it's a pleasure to meet you you
know when you meet the girl's father you
know why we're at home you know is that
how you do it
um I'm daddy you could be that okay this
is my daughter you're dating sure hi hi
this is I'm not gonna say it
um so uh so yeah sir sir uh
hey nice to meet you hey Rick uh he's
for horses old man wow
wow sorry Dad is your daughter he's
autistic
hey Daddy is your daughter of health
insurance daddy does your daughter have
health insurance
well let me know when she does because I
have a feeling I might split her open oh
wait
we I have okay
to what you said I agree it's so much
better and this is the type of people
that we are is like be in the moment
don't do something that you're supposed
to do because it shows that you're good
like just be yourself be organic at the
moment but Counterpoint to that there
might be some people that don't have the
self-confidence to like know how to be
in the moment and so they only know how
to follow a certain rule book it doesn't
necessarily mean that there are crazy
bad person absolutely totally okay I
just want to put that there but I'm I'm
like a perfect example of that I'm in
I'm a very in retrospect kind of girl
because I when I'm nervous I cannot be
in the moment like I am just surviving
the moment I'm very clear
um an hour after or maybe when my you
know I have my faculties about me again
but if I'm just like I I'll always
there's usually that's why I'm a an
apology person it's always you're going
to get a text later and it's going to be
a very cool clear retro you know in
retrospect text
um
so I don't behave in my most authentic
self kind of default to A playbook that
is more comfortable because it's a
survival playlist but there are ways uh
that there isn't anybody who is going to
be able to change or fix that if it's
even something that's to be fixed but
there are ways and there are types of
energies and communication to where when
if we're talking and you are that way
and I recognize that either by just
getting to know you or you at least
having the skill set of being able to
say hey I just want to let you know I'm
a little triggered and I'm a little out
of it right now or whatever to know that
things are different where you could
just like board really
should we stop
where you could be like you could be
like what's going on and get you get
someone back to prison what are you so
nervous about
you know that makes me nervous being
like even saying oh what are you so
nervous about I didn't mean it's so
judgmental I'm sorry wait I have to
explain myself now I just can we just
get through this I'm just surviving and
I'm here and we'll figure it out as we
go and I'll explain all my weird little
over blinking later yeah that's fine
um absolutely do you want to watch Shark
Tank
do I want to watch Shark Tank yeah
together are you guys on a date right
now well I'm saying like yeah I would
say am I still her dad are we doing this
what are you doing
I don't know why I keep looking at you
and wanting to undress and I don't think
it's a sexual thing I I got to tell you
please tell me it's not please I need
that to not be sexual only for you
there's something wrong with your job
eggster we should call you
um are you you're doing all right
financially right
are you gonna get your teeth fixed
what's going on
how to put my sunglasses back on
um I think we are it looks like you have
a big tooth
[Music]
there is uh my friend's sister
um had had a very very big gap in her
tooth and instead of putting
um instead of getting braces the Gap was
big enough they put in effect she opted
I don't know if it's in a comedic way or
just out of like pure um I think
function she put just one tooth in the
middle of her Gap and I think it's
[__] both genius and hilarious
because it's like oh she has a front
Chomper now it just looks a little
strange right but so I think really the
color of your tongue and the way it
splits it looks like you're both
dehydrated and probably an idiot that's
just a geographical tongue we're here to
defend you us sir look at her tongue
look closely at that tongue it's just
Geographic that's a healthy tongue yeah
we all have different types yours too I
scraped this morning let me see yours I
don't show I don't only show my tongue
on patreon
um we are out of time which is just too
bad I do advise that you girls put on
headphones for your next podcast why
it's all you're it's off what are you
talking about
you would understand if you put your
head can you explain it yeah there are
certain times where where we talk over
each other and I'll be the first to say
it I do it all the time and um you know
I talk a lot but with the headphone and
you don't have to stop talking but but
you're missing stuff you're those things
you're not hearing while you're talking
and not that those things aren't
necessarily important but it's
information that you're missing and it
can make you and I am again I do mean
this in a shitty way it will make you
quicker and I think you could use that
thank you yeah I will I will I actually
don't think I missed anything but I'm
open to I'm open to being wrong
you were so funny last night thank you
yeah
yeah Rick we've really missed you yeah
yeah me personally I I really really I I
realize I don't
like I don't realize how much I miss you
until I see you again what is it that
reminds you
see seeing you just seeing me it's not
like an energy it's just like all right
that guy I enjoyed this guy's company
yeah they really are
um yeah like when I'm away from you I
definitely don't want to be seeing you
honestly I really I said it to my
girlfriend I said I don't really think
that Esther is my argen Nemesis uh I do
think she's shaped like an arch nemesis
however like you know she's a girl that
I know that I no longer trust because I
find her to be selfish and very involved
with money however when I see her
by the way projecting I'm not going to
get into
but not projecting
um I see you and I am reminded and it's
not that I don't believe it but I am
reminded like I have it's almost always
a good time yeah I almost always because
no matter how disgusting you are or how
quick-witted I am we find a way for me
to be funny in you to laugh at it and I
just think that's really important for
my self-worth no but jokes aside I saw
you I hadn't seen you in however long
the music I just know you're down we did
the spin we did the thing you're we are
into it I'm into it it's very easy yes
so I don't forget with you I always
enjoy your company so it's this
this right it's like it works it works
it really works it does and this works
and I'm glad that we were able to do
this thank you we appreciate it
absolutely
um the first appearance I had I was it
was a different energy from all of us
and it was highly sexual well she we
were well this song you're just talking
about what kind of dicks you guys like
and no this wasn't this this was almost
zero sexually great but to me it wasn't
the sexual energy that was different
that really because we were in lingerie
Rick it's so funny that you even
remember I have no memory of what
happened I remember the I remember the
it was more that and that was more
common with what this is this is I think
we're all in a new space none of us have
pooped you pooped a lot or not enough
not enough right no I haven't pooped
since I think the last trash Tuesday so
this was lower but it was it was nice
but it was nice
but I think I think next time we should
all poop before the pod that's fine well
you wanted to do it at 11AM so which
thank you for I have a day I have a day
totally I'm just saying I normally don't
like to because I need to poop before
too I understand so plug by the way
um part of our day we did Color Me Mine
and we didn't finish so we're gonna go
and finish that's adorable yeah all
right really good well wait do couples
do that
sweet but the new couple new couples do
that I love doing things like that no I
love it too so can I come with
yeah do you want to meet us there I
can't today but do you want me to come
back yeah I'll stay longer when do you
want to go you want you want to go to
Color Me Mine with with me and my girl I
would love to probably you know when
she's in La let's all go would you like
to come not today
I meant in L.A oh yeah there's one right
by me do you think we could get them to
sponsor the episode and we could film it
there
I don't know but it's interesting that
you're interested in getting a sponsor
it seems like you projected something
earlier a few moments ago about me oh I
won't argue I could see you're being
really defensive about that that matters
to you oh yeah this is part of the
business where you try to get filming I
love that about you you being about your
bag thank you it's my favorite thing
about you that's why her and I can go on
and on and on about just you know Mogul
ideas yeah Rick thank you so much I had
such a good time I loved it thank you
Ricky are so awesome today
Mr Schwarzenegger I want to say
um thank you for having we could call
this episode um instead of part two T2
and have the thumbnail be you and to put
a red light in your glasses thank you um
so I guess uh if there's anything I was
here to plug it would be Color Me Mine
and
um Esther
and thank you again
all right
oh don't you do you normally close on
like a big laugh
Esther do your uh half Jewish half
regular yeah do that joke we'll see you
guys next week with a brand new episode
and uh that's all for now
thanks guys thanks for all the times
[Music]
thank you